[音楽]
あなたが
優しい
[音楽]
嘘ならない
星野はあなた
聞いていただきありがとうございました
私は歌が大好きで去年の文化祭の
プレゼンテーションに歌を歌わせて
いただきましたそして歌謡祭といった歌を
活かすイベントに周りの方々からの正体の
感想はとても良く私は自分自身で自分は歌
が上手いのだと思うようになりました
そこで今回この舞台に立って私は自分の
将来の夢である歌手という夢について
話そうと思っていました
しかし今日する話はその夢の話ではあり
ません
今日私がお話しするのはこのテッドに出る
にあたって自分と向き合い試行錯誤した
経験についてお話ししようと思います
先ほども申し上げた通り私は歌が大好き
でしたそしてもう一つ掲げていた目標が
ありましたそれは世界を幸せにすること
です
何を小学生のようなこと言っているのだと
思う人がいるかもしれませんそれでも私は
真剣にこの課題の取り組みたいと思ってい
ました
そして私は自分の得意な方法で世界の幸せ
に貢献するために自分の歌で世界を幸せに
できるような歌手になるという漠然とした
夢を掲げていました
しかしそんな私に天気が譲ります
それはこのテントに出るにあたって自分で
歌詞を書いていたらどうかと言われたとき
でし
ただって私は自分の言いたいことが出てこ
なくなってしまったのです
そしてその時にどうしても恥ずかしさが
拭えなかったのです
そこで私は気づいてしまいました自分は歌
にメッセージを載せて伝えるということが
恥ずかしくてできないということ
さらにもう一つ気づいてしまったことが
ありますそれはまたこの店舗に出るに
あたって自分がどうして歌詞になりたかっ
たのかとまた考え直してみたの
私はまた気づいてしまいました
世界を幸せにするためには歌詞よりも
もっといい方法があるのではないかと
例えば
政治家になったとしたらどうでしょう自分
の発言をより直接的に政治に作用させる
ことができるのではないでしょうか
カジノの影響力のある人間はたくさんあり
ますそれでも私は先ほども申し上げた通り
自分の思いを歌にメッセージとして載せて
伝えるということが恥ずかしくてできない
ん
ですそのため私は歌を使ったお仕事をする
ことそれが世界を幸せにすることこれを
天秤にかけてみました
私にとってはどちらが重要なの
かそして私の結果後者を選びました
世界の幸せに
ここまで聞くと自分の本当にやりたいこと
が見つかって喜ばしいことのように思える
かもしれませ
ん実際私もそう思っていますしかしそれ
よりも大きな感情が私を襲ったのですそれ
は何でしょう
それは不安です今まで歌手っていう漠然と
しては一応将来の夢であるものが
崩れ落ちてしまったり自分のやっていく
ことに対する
肯定の気持ちや自信が一気に失われていた
のです
また歌手という夢がその自分の今やって
いることに対する
肯定の素材や自信の存在でしかないことが
気づきそんな自分のままでいいのかとも
思いました
そして私は猛烈に反省しました
どうして今まで自分の将来について深く
考えてこなかったんだろう
しかし
反省しても何も出ませんでした私は今自分
のやるべきことがわからなくなってしまっ
たの
ですところがこれをある先生に相談した時
にその先生がこう言いますそれがリアル
12らしい考え方なのです
が私は自分の考えていること悩んでいる
ことを自分以外の人間が持っているという
ことに安心しましたしかしそれ以上に自分
の人生において自分の将来に深く
考えるとその悩みが必然的に生まれてくる
ものだと言われているような気がしてその
悩みを抱けている自分を誇られていました
そして今私が将来の対策不安や今自分が
やるべきことがわからないことに対する
ほとんどありません
それは歌手歌手になって成功できたかと
いうのは他人があるまで決めることですが
世界を幸せにできたかということを決める
のは自分だと思えるよう
ですつまり自分のやりたいこと最終目標を
定義づけられるのも自分という存在に
置き換わったからです
また今までの私は歌手になるという目標
から逆算して今自分のやるべきことを決め
ていましたが今の私は
フォーキャスティングと言って今これから
自分がやることやること経験することを
最終的に世界に幸せにつなげていければ
いいな自分のこれから経験することの
積み重ねが大事なのだなと思えるように
変わりました
本来私がこのセットに出て自分の歌を歌っ
て自分の歌の話をして止められたい自信を
つけたいなどの気持ちが強かったように
思います
そのため私がその歌の話をできないと自分
で察した時に不安になったのを覚えてい
ますそれはこのテッドが意義のないものに
なってしまうのではないかということでし
た
しかし今の私は最終的にこの悩みを持てた
こととても喜ばしいことだと思います
私が
私は最初セットに応募するという経験から
当初話したかったことと忘れてしまいまし
たが自分の人生において大切な知識や
経験になるこういった自分の悩み思ってた
ことをとても
喜ばしいことだと思った皆さんに応えて
もらいたいと思います
これは
計画的偶発性理論と言ってスタンフォード
大学にジョンディープランボルツ社が提供
した人生において自分の予想している
プランの8割を上手くいかない
そのことを私はこれからもポジティブに
捉えて自分を変えるような大きな変化を
これからも受け入れていこうと思います
そして今の私はというと自分の得意な方法
でもう一度世界の幸せのために何ができる
だろうかと作中ですそして今日が新たな
スタートとなるでしょうありがとうござい
ました